die Krankheit über die wir heute
sprechen betrifft weltweit 32% der
Erwachsenen 40% der Männer und etwa 25%
der Frauen und das schlimmste ist die
meisten Betroffenen wissen gar nicht
dass sie krank sind dabei leiden sie
unter einem höheren Risiko für
Herzkreislauferkrankungen und im
fortgeschrittenen Stadium ist die
Krankheit inzwischen die häufigste
Ursache für Lebertransplantationen und
Leberkrebs wie kann eine so verbreitete
Krankheit gleichzeitig so unbekannt sein
und was kann man dagegen tun heute geht
es um den Stoffwechsel um Körperfett und
Ernährung übergewicht ist einer der
Risikofaktoren für diese Krankheit aber
bevor du jetzt denkst das betrifft dich
nicht auch jemand mit einem BMI im
Normalbereich kann diese Krankheit
bekommen die neuesten
Forschungsergebnisse könnten dich dazu
bringen dein Leben zu verändern deswegen
haben wir die Forscherinnen und Forscher
besucht die diese Krankheit aufhalten
wollen sie entwickeln mit innovativen
Geräten Computermodell künstlicher
Intelligenz und einer Menge Pipetten
eine Technologie die ganz einfach Leben
retten kann und ich erkläre euch jetzt
wie bevor wir uns die Krankheit im
Detail anschauen machen wir noch mal
einen Schritt zurück wie und bei wem
entwickelt sie sich wichtige
Risikofaktoren dafür sind
Stoffwechselerkrankungen wie Diabetes
und auch Übergewicht ist mit einem
höheren Risiko verbunden aber die
Entstehung von Übergewicht ist echt lex
dazu haben wir übrigens schon mal ein
ganzes Video gemacht klar da spielen
Ernährung und Bewegungsmangel eine Rolle
aber längst nicht nur auch die Erziehung
Gewohnheiten und die Psyche sind
entscheidend und ein weiterer Grund ist
die genetische
Prädisposition früher war es natürlich
von Vorteil wenn der Körper schnell
Fettreserven anlegt darum ist die
genetische Veranlagung zum Fettspeichern
auch relativ weit verbreitet aber heute
ist die Veranlagung kein Vorteil mehr
weil Fett und zuckerreiche Lebensmittel
überall sind der Konsum von diesen
hochverarbeiteten Produkten korreliert
mit Übergewicht und die Zahlen steigen
in Deutschland ist mittlerweile über die
Hälfte der Erwachsenen betroffen
weltweit sind 13% adipös also krankhaft
übergewichtig aber wie schon gesagt auch
normalgewichtige Menschen können die
Krankheit bekommen und auch hierbei
spielen die Gene eine wichtige Rolle
trotzdem man ist auch mit der
genetischen Veranlagung nicht seinem
Schicksal ausgeliefert es ist nicht
einmal ers kompliziert diese Krankheit
zu verhindern wie genau das erklären wir
später im Video noch besonders
gefährlich ist es wenn sich fett im
Bauchraum anlagert dieses sogenannte
viszerale Fett umgibt die Organe und
kann sich sogar in den Organen anlagern
z.B in der Leber und genau da entsteht
die Krankheit über die wir heute reden
es geht um die sogenannte Fettleber die
Leber ist das größte innere Organ des
Körpers sie ist eine Art Hauptbahnhof
für unseren Stoffwechsel alle Minuten
filtert sie das komplette Blut in deinem
Körper die Leber ist viel cooler als ihr
Ruf es vielleicht vermuten lässt auch
wenn über zwei Drittel davon fehlen z.B
als Folge einer Operation kann sie sich
noch regenerieren aber unzerstörbar ist
sie natürlich auch wieder nicht okay
also wie entsteht so eine Fettleber
viele denken da ja zuerst einmal an
Alkohol und ja aufgrund von Alkohol kann
es dazu kommen aber das geht auch ganz
ohne Alkohol wenn die Leber zu viel
Zucker bekommt wandelt sie diesen
überschüssigen Zucker in Fett um und
lagert ihn in Fetttröpfchen ab eine
nichtalkkoholische Fettlebererkrankung
entsteht diese Krankheit wird abgekürzt
auch einfach naffelt genannt aber trotz
des Namens kann sie auch bei Personen
auftreten die z.B ein wenig Alkohol
trinken aber der ist dann eben nicht
ursächlich denn die Fettleber entsteht
dann durch andere Stoffwechselprozesse
sogar Kinder und Jugendliche können
davon betroffen sein aber nur weil
Alkohol nicht an einer naffelt Schuld
ist ist sie deswegen nicht weniger
gefährlich die schädliche Entwicklung in
der Leber ist zwar noch lange umkehrbar
aber irgendwann wird ein Kipppunkt
überschritten an dem die naffelt sogar
zu Leberkrebs führen kann und bevor wir
zur eigentlichen Forschung kommen müssen
wir noch kurz verstehen wie dieser Krebs
schlussendlich entsteht das liegt
nämlich an einer der eigentlich tollen
Eigenschaften der Leber die ihr aber zum
Verhängnis wird wenn das Lebergewebe
geschädigt wird kann es sich anfangs gut
reparieren aber W wen es immer wieder
gereizt wird dann kommt es zu
Entzündungen und zur vernarung sobald
ein Großteil der Leber vernart ist
spricht man von einer zirrose in diesem
Zustand ist das Risiko für Leberkrebs
deutlich erhöht und die Leber hat ihre
Funktion fast verloren allerdings kann
dieser Zustand auch übersprungen werden
die Leber geht dann also direkt von der
Verfettung und der Entzündung zum
Leberkrebs über und dieser ständige Reiz
diese ständige Entzündungsvorgänge die
führen dazu dass dann immer wieder
Zellen auch neu gebildet werden müssen
also sich teilen diese Zell poifation
nennt man das die führt dann dazu dass
auch das Risiko im mehr steigt dass
liberkrebs entstehen kann das ist
Professor ursola klingmüller sie forscht
am Deutschen Krebsforschungszentrum am
Zusammenhang zwischen der naffelt und
Leberkrebs gerade entwickelt sie mit
ihrem Team ein Tool mit dem du schnell
und einfach erfahren kannst wie hoch
dein individuelles leberkrebsrisiko ist
Professor klingmüller und ihr Team erfor
vor allem diesen zweiten also eher
untypischen Weg zum Leberkrebs ohne eine
zirrose als Zwischenstadium diese
Variante tritt zwar nur in einem kleinen
Teil der Fälle auf aber weil so viele
Personen von einer naffelt betroffen
sind ihr erinnert euch knapp ein Drittel
der Menschheit ist die Zahl trotzdem
nicht zu vernachlässigen dafür
untersuchen sie wie der Krebs genau
entsteht und was dabei in den Zellen
passiert und da spielt ein Proteinen
eine wichtige Rolle die entzündungsreize
lösen Stress in den Leberzellen aus
darum um schüttet der Körper HGF aus das
ist ein Wachstumsfaktor ein spezielles
Protein das HGF dockt an die Leberzellen
an die das Signal ins Innere der Zellen
weitergeben ähnlich wie beim
Dominoeffekt das wird auch Signalkaskade
genannt am Ende steht dann die
Zellteilung HGF löst also über die
Signalkaskade aus dass sich die Zelle
teilt aber was passiert jetzt wenn viel
Glucose also Zucker vorhanden ist das
hat Christina Mölders in der Petrischale
untersucht sie ist Doktorandin im Team
von Professor klingmüller ich habe
Zellen in einen nählösung gehalten die
viel Glucose hatte und in einer
näherlösung die wenig Glukose hatte und
habe dann wieder mit dem Wachstumsfaktor
HGF stimuliert und mir eben die
Weitergabe von Signalen angeschaut also
prlyferier die Zelle wächst die Zelle
oder kommt die zu einem Wachstumsstopp
die Signalkaskade verändert sich also
wenn Zucker verfügbar ist und dabei kann
es passieren dass eine Zelle
kontinuierlich das Signal bekommt sich
zu teilen und je öfter das passiert
desto größer ist die Chance dass dabei
Krebs entsteht um aber ganz genau zu
verstehen welcher Prozess durch was
ausgelöst wird nutzt das Team diese
krassen Geräte Computermodelle und
künstliche
Intelligenz zuerst werden Leberzellen
von Patientinnen und Patienten in
verschiedenen Krankheitsstadien
untersucht dafür werden die Zellen aus
einer Probe aufgelöst oder lysiert und
dann mit so einem Massenspektrometer
untersucht MST welche Proteine in
welcher Menge in der Probe enthalten
sind wenn man diese Tests mit Zellen aus
den verschiedenen Proben über längere
Zeit wiederholt kann man solche Kurven
anfertigen daran lässt sich erkennen wie
sich die Zusammensetzung der Zelle über
die Zeit im Krankheitsverlauf verändert
und daraus kann man dann schließen wie
sich die Krankheit weiterentwickeln wird
und hier kommt dann auch künstliche
Intelligenz ins Spiel KI ist besonders
gut darin Muster zu erkennen aber
Achtung das sind letztendlich immer nur
Korrelationen die Forscher wollen aber
natürlich auch die Mechanismen also die
Zusammenhänge zwischen Ursache und
Wirkung verstehen z.B welches Protein
löst was aus trotzdem unterstützt KI das
Team dabei über alle Aspekte den
Überblick zu behalten das Ziel sind
mathematische Modelle mit denen sich die
Vorgänge besonders gut vorhersagen
lassen dafür muss das Team unter den
vielen Proteinen diejenigen finden die
schon früh auf einen Leberkrebs
hinweisen wenn man dann das von
Patientinnen und Patienten untersucht
kann man diese sogenannten Biomarker
nachweisen und damit den
Krankheitsverlauf Abschätzen der Patient
kommt es wird Blut abgenommen und wir
wollen damit testen dann ganz einfach
ist das ein Patient der ein erhöhtes
Risiko hat und dass dann der Arzt sagen
kann dieser Patient soll möglicherweise
in ein Jahr wiederkommen oder in drei
Monaten und er bräuchte jetzt eine
zusätzliche Untersuchung durch MRT oder
CT also medizinische
Bildgebung und so Patienten sozusagen
zuordnen und mit einer verbesserten
Vorsorgeuntersuchung versehen wenn Sie
es wirklich brauchen okay was bedeutet
das jetzt genau na ja das Tool wird
komplett verändern wie wir mit naffelt
Umgehen von der Diagnose bis zur
Therapie in schätzungsweise 5 Jahren
kannst du beim Blut abnehmen mit dem
Biomarker Test einfach dein
individuelles Risiko für Leberkrebs
durch eine naffelt ermitteln lassen und
dein Arzt kann dir dann frühzeitig
Hinweise zur Prävention geben jetzt
gerade kann dir kein Arzt der Welt sagen
wie sich eine naffeld verändern wird und
das finde ich mega krass wir leben in
der spannendsten Zeit der
Menschheitsgeschichte in der wir einfach
mit künstlicher Intelligenz menschlicher
Intelligenz und cooler Forschung Leben
retten geil yes SCI mit dem Modell lässt
sich dann voraussagen wie nah oder fern
der Kipppunkt zum Leberkrebs noch ist
wenn alles entspannt ist dann reicht es
vielleicht einmal im Jahr die Leberwerte
zu kontrollieren wenn der kippunkt
allerdings schon kurz bevor steht wirst
du häufiger und mit verschiedenen
Methoden untersucht und das ist die
Zukunft personalisierte Medizin weil so
viele von einer naffild betroffen sind
ist das aber nur realistisch wenn wir
eine günstige schnelle Untersuchung
haben und da ist ein einfacher bluest
ein riesiger Fortschritt okay das war
die Theorie aber jetzt zur Praxis wie
kann ich meine Leber schützen die
Antwort ist leider genauso simpel wie
schwierig umsetzbar mit einem gesunden
Lebensstil dadurch kannst du
Stoffwechselerkrankungen entgegenwirken
und damit auch einer naffelt vorbeugen
in der Praxis sieht das dann so aus dass
man wirklich versucht Kleinigkeiten in
seinen Alltag zu integrieren z.B dass
man einfach mal häufiger die Treppe
nutzt anstatt immer mit dem Aufzug zu
fahren oder eben anstatt von süßen
Getränken dann einfach mal Wasser
trinken eine Möglichkeit was man machen
kann ist auch sich bewusst machen diese
Snacks die man sich angewöhnt hat dass
man am Computer Chips Kekse Schokolade
oder was stehen hat und das so ziemlich
unbewusst so ständig
ist das ist etwas wo man sehr viel
machen könnte denn der Körper ist an
sich darauf eingestellt auch immer
wieder Hungerperioden zu erleiden ob das
jetzt bedeutet dass man mal das
Abendessen auslässt oder dass man ab und
zu einen ganzen Tag fastet das kann
jeder individuell entscheiden beides
hilft dem Stoffwechsel und damit der
Leber übrigens die Kombi aus Fett und
Zucker ist schädlich aber keine Sorge es
ist völlig okay mal etwas fettiges oder
mal etwas Süßes zu essen die Zeitspanne
von der naild zum Leberkrebs beträgt
durchschnittlich mehrere Jahrzehnte
trotzdem ist es wichtig der Leber auch
mal eine Pause zu gönnen und je früher
man das auf dem Schirm hat desto kleiner
sind die Einschränkungen und die
eventuellen Folgen und da die meisten dr
Watson Zuschauer relativ jung sind sind
das gute Nachrichten für
euch es warga spannend die Labore zu
besuchen und Vorort zu sehen wie an
Leberkrebs geforscht wird und ich hoffe
natürlich dass wir mit diesem Video hier
dazu beitragen dass mehr Leute diese
gefährliche aber vermeidbare Krankheit
im Blick haben fun fact gerade wird in
den gleichen Laboren vom gleichen Team
auch an Lungenkrebs Leukämie und dem
Zusammenspiel von Leber Lunge und Herz
geforscht die häufigsten Todesursachen
weltweit sind nämlich
Herzkreislauferkrankungen und Krebs
durch den interdisziplinären Ansatz des
Projekts werden Bereiche
zusammengebracht die vorher fast nur
isoliert voneinander betrachtet wurden
nice das Projekt dass diese Forschung
zur Fettleber möglich macht heißt Smart
naffeld wenn ihr mehr darüber erfahren
wollt schaut euch die Links unten in der
Videobeschreibung an mit zwei weiteren
Forschungsprojekten zu Leberkrebs ergibt
sich daraus das Netzwerk lisum Krebs das
vom Bundesministerium für Bildung und
Forschung gefördert wird dieses Video
hier ist auch in Zusammenarbeit mit dem
BMBF und dem Projektträger Jü standen
danke an das Bundesministerium für
Bildung und Forschung danke an euch fürs
zuschauen und bis zum nächsten Mal
bleibt neugierig euer Cedrick